well you went like bungee jumping which
sounds pretty dangerous no body shopping
it's fine it's not like okay you see
there's videos of body jumping going
wrong uh and you're like oh God but then
I feel like if if I'm gonna bungee jump
anywhere I trust the Japan they'd take
all the measures and that they would do
it right I didn't feel it all in danger
bungee jumping was really cool though I
really liked it a lot it is strange
because it was like
uh I've never done it before and I was
really hyped to try it I knew Chris was
very much not hyped to try it in fact he
didn't even want to go near it yeah
um and I I knew I would like it but and
I I in the video it's like all right
okay like I I don't know how to do like
I don't get scared and stuff like that I
don't know why because I just trust that
everything works yeah and if something
goes wrong all right well GG yeah
yeah like but also on the video you have
to like pretend to be a bit more scared
than you are because you know you ham it
up yeah
but there is that like one second window
where you jump out and the bungee jump
hasn't like like uh tensioned yet yeah
you're like whoa you're just in free
fall yeah it's really cool it's like you
kind of in this it's not even a second
it's like less than this it's like half
a second of like holy [__] this is what
it would feel like if you just jumped
off a cliff yeah like just this falling
and the picking up the speed and the
scariest thing is just seeing the floor
get way closer to you really fast yeah
yeah and then and then the bungee you
know it tenses and then you're like okay
all right and then it becomes more like
a ride right right but for that for
those 0.5 seconds where you you jump and
you just see the floor and you're like
whoa that's it that's an amazing you
feel the zero G's all right dude it's
sick yeah it's sick it's so good I get
why people get addicted to it I still
wouldn't want to do it no it's weird I'm
scared advice isn't it well that's the
thing I don't I don't want to do bungee
jumping ever but I want to try skydiving
yeah because it's like I feel when it
gets the sky diving levels when you jump
out of that again I don't know right
this is just all speculation but I would
feel the moment I jump out of the plane
maybe for the first second or so I'd be
like I'm practically [__] right now
I'm [__] my pants that I've just
flown I've jumped out of this vehicle
yeah but then after a while you just
like you just enjoy the free fall right
it's just like oh I'm good like you know
I've got a parachute I got an instructor
probably like you know and it'll be fine
I feel like I feel like skydiving safer
than Ubuntu jumping though I think I
think the one thing about skydiving that
makes it less scary in my mind is that
the floor from that high up like the
ground doesn't feel real no no because
there's no like perspective it's like
computer generation but I think the
thing that makes bungee's jumping so
scary is how close you get to the ground
and also it just looks like a normal
View and you're just jumping yeah like
it's like when you see videos of
skydiving you're like bro this looks
like man just jumped out on like of the
Sim City yeah like looking down yeah I
mean like it doesn't look and I I know
that obviously it is going to be scared
me a lot but it doesn't feel like that
when you're watching it I've never tried
skydiving I really want to
um but yeah just I mean that's the way I
I see it yeah and I think um
yeah how close you get to the floor is
definitely terrifying in that place as
well that they had this like swing and
that was way scarier it's a giant swing
and the reason why it's scary is because
you don't get to decide when they drop
you and that's what's terrifying because
it's kind of like you're just sitting
there and then suddenly boom you're
falling right and again it does
intention for about half a second and it
it dude it's terrifying the fact that
you get to decide when you jump and when
you start speeding down yeah is
definitely a massive factor in what
makes bungee jumping feel more kind of
in control and more fun yeah but the
fact that you can't you can't that's
just anxiety inducing isn't it yeah well
yeah you're sitting there and he's like
ready you're like yeah
have you seen those videos of the guy
doing the bungee jumping but he's like
attached to the chair uh no I haven't
seen that okay so there's this video I
saw quite a while ago of this guy um I
think it was on Tick Tock or YouTube
shorts or whatever but it's bungee
jumping but instead of you know you
standing at the edge and then you
jumping whenever you're ready to go yeah
you're you're essentially strapped to a
chair yeah like a regular ass just like
plastic chair and you don't get to go
because you'll it's like a hostage
situation like you just you just attach
this chair and the instructor just like
spot and kicks you off oh
ever since I was a kid there like I
always just love that stuff too yeah see
I think that's the reason why I managed
to get go through my entire childhood
without going to the hospital is because
I never looked for that address I've
never broken anything though I I like
you're so lucky bro I think so yeah I've
had some pretty bad Falls and but I've
never broken anything I don't know um
I like my adrenaline as well uh I just
like it to be controlled because I think
the the difference between five shots of
adrenaline yeah let's let's say the
difference between a roller coaster
Western snowboarding is that I don't
trust myself I trust myself way less
than going on like rails yeah but I
think that's what makes uh snowboarding
more adrenaline inducing it's like
that's it it's it's the risk right it's
the risk there's no risk on a roller
coaster so roller coasters I'm kind of
like so I'm more afraid of a roller
coaster than I am of snowboarding though
why I don't know maybe I'm the opposite
I trust I trust myself more than some
Randolph but the odds of you hurting
yourself is so much higher I know but
maybe I don't think about that yeah
it's the feeling it's the feeling of
like yeah I'm in control of it it's like
it's my body I I have full control of it
whereas if I'm on a roller coaster I'm
like uh you know there's there's lots of
people I can blame if this goes wrong
you know not and none of them are me
I think uh the the bad thing about being
an adrenaline junkie though uh is that
sometimes you have to the voices in your
head are like do it do that it'll be fun
it'll be fun and then you're like God I
should but I'm right yeah unless
I always love doing uh jumps and on
skiing or snowboarding yeah dude it's
like the easiest way to [__] know
yourself yeah it's so easy to hurt
yourself yeah uh but and you know every
time you do a jump you're like maybe you
can go a little faster next time I think
we get a little higher and every time
you do you're like oh oh I nearly messed
up that Landing that would have been bad
yeah because you know there's a lot of
speed a lot of momentum and you don't
really get to fall nicely on a skew or a
snowball when strapped into you no so uh
so far I haven't had an awesome one in a
long time
it's been a hot minute since I really
hurt myself on a skit your snowboard I
mean future that's good though yeah yeah
let's keep it that way maybe next time
did you see the Clipper posted of me
doing uh
it was so hard to get it framed though
yeah because in real life you move so
much more than you know obviously you
can anticipate so yeah and one time
Lottery was like I'll be your cameraman
so he's my cameraman while I'm doing the
jumps and of course as he's going to the
jump you know he's he assumes a position
and immediately as I'm I'm about to take
the jump he bends down so you just miss
it and I'm like oh [__] me but it was
cool getting them to do that and get in
the it's it's surreal watching it back
because you you watch the jump and
you're like oh wow that looked way
cooler in my head that it did on the
camera yeah uh potentially get some air
and stream it which I think is pretty
cool I mean there's a reason why games
like SSX tricky are in third person not
first person yeah I think that's true
also it's pretty like sickening it looks
way cooler in third post it most
certainly does yeah it's cool though
being able to do that I think yeah for
sure man I don't know how often I'll do
that it was kind of tough I mean
I think it's amazing that you know like
you said we have gotten to the point
where you can stream something that's so
cool
um but at the same time yeah [__] I
don't need another layer of complex
complexity to add of me like trying to
hurt myself as well that's [__]
terrifying it's like oh I I now I'm in
the trouble of hurting myself and all of
this expensive equipment on my back
I was more worried about the backpack
than me I was like Hey a broken bones
but the equipment nah it takes a while
to replace you know I can I can get a
new leg this equipment's more expensive
than I am yeah you know what I mean
I've been skiing for a while
snowboarding and I was like man I kind
of wish I could have died do something
with it wish I could like stream it turn
it into content well just because that's
the YouTuber brain but also I you know I
think sometimes when you get pretty good
at stuff like that it's kind of easy to
be like well it doesn't really you know
didn't really do anything yeah it's kind
of like doesn't do it for me anymore
what happens when you don't have any
hobbies anymore you're like it's true is
there anything left in my life that I
can monetize
that's true that's true this is a lot
yeah I'm doing it purely for enjoyment
who does that I don't know it's like
it's like a fun thing to
test
um and I just like I like messing with
stuff and I like trying to figure out if
some things work yeah and I always
thought that yeah man this theoretically
there's nothing stopping you from
streaming skiing it's just why it's the
big one and then yeah I tried it and it
kind of worked some some bits didn't
think you can do it again yeah I'd
really love to do uh uh like a a ski
trip for like a one one or two days
probably two days but then like everyone
had a backpack on or like at least
people who were pretty confident they
wouldn't fall over right so maybe not
you yeah
maybe some other competent skiers or
snowboarders who are pretty sure they're
not gonna fall over yeah can have it
probably Manu right yeah man it would be
good yeah man would be good if you hold
me on some skis I could probably do it
as well yeah right like I think uh it's
easier not to fall if your goal is to
not fall yeah I think if you ski wow
um words of wisdom right there Mr skis
sorry I mean I'm trying to avoid it
because like if you don't want to fall
just don't fall there is a way to to ski
if you've never done it that is very
safe yeah very hard to [__] up and fall
over unless you pretty much try to yeah
obviously if you're not a beginner yeah
um snowboarding a little less so
um and so I think that you could do it
where you'd be like all right if I have
the bag on I'll be a safe boy nothing
fancy I mean you know during the road
trip right like when we got those shots
of our skiing like Manu was holding a
very expensive camera oh yeah
going very fast but he was he was chill
with it yeah yeah it's a bit too chill I
was like fighting for my life in the
slope and he just goes past me backwards
holding a camera I'm like [__] you man
yeah such a flex
nobody's goddamn Europeans it's fun I I
started doing the thing where you just
spin around when I was with the camera
but it just looks like you're just
disorientating people yeah I'm like damn
it doesn't you don't realize like damn
that's that's kind of hard to do it's
kind of hard to show you guys yeah
exactly exactly I guess it's fun it was
really interesting it was a cool test
um I I basically saw that Rob did it
that's how I do most of my streams I've
robbed at it I was like
I always thought man I should try it but
I just didn't know if you could get a
signal and the answer is you kind of can
yeah we could get signal on the main
slope but the moment we went into like
valleys it just died yeah yeah because
uh when we because I just came back from
Journey Across Japan five yeah and uh
Pete who was with us yeah uh he streamed
like the behind the scenes for like a
couple of days yeah I saw it yeah it was
really really cool and it was like the
most remote parts of Hokkaido yeah
exactly and it's like you know obviously
some parts like the the signal was dying
but it was surprising the amount of
places we actually got signaled yeah
Japan's really [__] good with signal
yeah um if this was in Wales it wouldn't
it couldn't be done yeah I remember not
even Cardiff I remember IRL streaming in
Brighton one of the major cities in the
UK it was like dropping out left right
and center the moment I got like even
like 50 meters radius of the beach yeah
oh I guess okay Signal's gone can't
shoot the beach guys sorry yeah
it's like I mean I obviously by the time
this comes out the my RV thing will be
done fingers crossed it all goes well
and smoothly and they'll be really funny
if it went terribly in this age poorly
but I'm showing great I prepared very
well
um yeah it's like you're already doing
on on location shoots is hard yeah then
when you have to be like okay we want to
shoot on this location
um but we need signal it's like oh
that's so that's a that's a big big
thing to worry about yeah now suddenly
you have to plan everything out about
where you maybe have something you have
to like to worry about yeah but this
this it's getting better and luckily
this is probably like one of the best
countries on Earth to kind of test
outdoor shooting and IRL stuff yeah yeah
or compared to some uh a lot of Western
countries I mean I mean when I when I
would like go home for example you know
I I would I the first time I went back
to the UK after living in Japan for like
two years went back and I was like yeah
man it feels good to just you know get
off the plane have 4G like great yeah
cause it's London and it kind of works
yeah then I remember getting the train
to Wales and literally the moment we got
out of like the greater London area I
was like oh I can't load a YouTube video
oh I remember I got in the habit of
downloading everything because this
happened all the time and I was like I'm
sure I'm sure I'll come back it did not
come back like at all until the train
stopped holy [__] it just did I could I
could maybe get a text in or a message
but like I I couldn't watch anything and
I was like oh this sucks like I guess if
you what did people do before
smartphones yeah I guess if you're just
like moving even in a remotely fast
speed in the UK it doesn't work well
yeah at least where the trains go
through I think the roads are a bit
better because more often than not cell
phone towers are built very closely to
roads yeah
um I I'm assuming I don't really know
why there just is same in Japan all the
because basically how I do a lot of the
deciding of can we film here or can I do
an IRL thing here is I have to go to a
cell phone map Tower right it's open
source and you have to go through all
the mobile networks in Japan and just
look and there'll be like dots of where
they are right yeah but if there's none
nearby it's like well guess we're not
doing it there yeah because I was about
to say it's like even like in Japan you
could be on the shinkansen traveling at
300 kilometers yeah that's so bad and
it's it's full bars the whole way yeah
oh really oh we came recently from
Hokkaido and at least for the first
three hours or two hours there was none
it was from Hokkaido yeah but that's
probably because you're in the The Long
Island Tunnel right there was the tunnel
and then you would come out of the
tunnel immediately go in another tunnel
go out of the tunnel going oh yeah yeah
um but yeah I mean normally in Japan
they just they built them all long roads
yeah I don't know if it's the same and
I'm assuming it's the same the rest of
the world but it was yeah yeah do your
tedious stuff